let me ask you guys this question about
height because i mean height is one of
the things that always comes up it's one
of the things a lot of guys like to just
focus on oh i'm not six foot tall i'm
[ __ ] right because you know we've all
seen women's dating apps say you know i
like tall guys or must be over six or
six foot one or six foot two sometimes
they even give you like an exact number
like you have to be at least six foot
two or something like that um how do you
guys deal with that because i know um
renegade's the only super tall guy here
i mean i got a funny story about that
it's a [ __ ] i'm the shortest
i'm five hi jason
i'm uh i'm 5 11 and so with boots on
because we wear boots everywhere yeah
easily so i'm sorry so i put i
yeah i just put six feet in all of
dating no one's ever said anything
because i'm not typically the gals i'm
dating are also maybe five two five
three they can't tell you yeah women are
short they don't know the difference
all right
paul you're like what five foot ten
five foot one no i'm just kidding yeah
about five foot nine and some change
which is how you know i'm about average
height because i i have to caveat that
half inch
yeah about five eleven six foot right
around where uh jb is irishman yep now
five nine
five nine yeah so i mean five nine so
yeah
i'm five i've said does height matter
yeah like women have said to me oh my
god you're so tall like they like
a tall big guy but it doesn't matter it
really doesn't matter i mean all all of
you guys have been in fact most of you
are under six what put it i gotta
like i tried no joke because i'm in
mexico now so i realized 180 centimeters
is like the six foot here i'm like oh
good i literally am 180 centimeters no
boots on boots on oh i'm way up there um
but when i've gone back to the states
too they see centimeters they're like oh
like what who are you like oh you're
from this town what but why centimeters
like oh yeah i live abroad and
you're peeking their interest again so
try try things out too that's it
too get creative like just
just steamroll that obstacle
yeah no it doesn't like i mean
women tend to think i'm taller just
because of the way i act i think you're
wider than you're taller
right yes yeah and that too you know
what they call it a [ __ ] brick house is
that the yeah that's right
brick [ __ ] house definitely a [ __ ]
but uh yeah so i i mean i found that it
didn't matter really like i've had women
that you know dated that were taller
than me and they just as long as
you are dominant and you dominate them
and then you make them feel small then
that's fine it's all about do they feel
small or not but i know we're talking
about apps and we got to cut through
some of that stuff
if you're on if you're not between six
since like
if not over six feet tall give yourself
a couple inches they lie on those things
just lie who cares because what's gonna
happen is you'll meet with them and
they'll be like
you know if they if they're curious
about it they'll might be like are you
so you're five eleven be like
ah
i i don't even remember what i put i
don't tell that she's ten pounds heavier
than her best photo like that's what i'm
saying
here's the thing i mean if you're five
foot one don't say you're six foot but
if you're like five foot ten you can get
away with six foot with boots right
she's like you're taller than her that's
it girls just want to date exactly she
just wants to be with a guy that's
bigger
guys that are that's about awareness
yeah right put the boots on you know
change your stuff
i'm about as wide as i am tall too so
i'm like okay well maybe i don't need to
build my back out that wide because then
i'll look more of a square i can kind of
lean the waist and
you you but you learn those things about
yourself the dating market gives you
feedback yeah yeah if you let it if you
pay attention if you actually listen to
women they are honest they will
you you think they're bullshitting
you'll be like oh no she literally means
that that that is what it is um and you
can take women are very honest with your
behavior i mean i'll tell you guys about
height like i mean like oh you're too
big you're too skinny you're too fat
you're too this like all right so what
are the are they sleeping with you so
what are the woes of being six foot six
renegade
uh well so at the six with six area i'm
actually like almost like i think the
perfect height is like six three that's
like i mean like you're one of the few
guys that i stand like six four like
and he's a tall dude and i'm like at
least six foot two right
right
from when they've run like numbers on it
women tend to like between six foot and
six foot four is about the cap and then
it starts to have diminished returns
yeah exactly exactly so i'm two inches
into that diminishing return side of the
equation um yeah i mean i'll say though
like i've definitely noticed like girls
tend to be like height supremacists as
we call them um because they definitely
have a very built-in and it's kind of
natural right you want that built-in
level of um security with your with your
partner but you know what i found is
especially with the the guys that i hang
with
a lot of the guys that i know that do
extremely well the most are the shorter
guys that well they might be like five
six but their personality seven foot
tall talk about the five talk about the
five foot six personality guy because
guys always question me on that i've
told the story about an old roommate
that i've had that was like five foot
four
he was a slayer pocket hercules yeah you
heard the story right yeah five foot six
so i'll go ahead and tell your story and
i'll just shut up so so i have what we
really
i wanna hear renegade story on the phone
i got a lot of stories with this guy uh
but he's yeah so he's one of those i'll
never forget because this guy
so there was this
team of like volleyball players that
came into this place that we're at like
from so all these girls are like minimum
like
511 right just tall amazonian just very
good-looking athletic girls and so um my
friend he's five foot six and he says
look it's like oh look at my friend was
like my other friend was like hey man
like look at all those tall girls like
trying to go to monolith he's like dude
let me get my personality axe i'm about
to go chop down some trees so literally
walks in that's awesome starts talking
to to all of them introduces us to
everyone
so one of the girls is like about six
one he winds up hooking up with her in
the bathroom at this place and
it's just like it's always one of those
examples that stood out to me because he
used to say i'm even though i'm five six
my personality's seven feet tall
and so it really is true about how he
really owns his skin and he's very
comfortable and he's like yeah okay you
know what i'm i'm short and there's
literally nothing i can do about that
but at the end of the day that it could
either be something that i get hung up
on personally or i just go out and just
own it
and really what it comes down to is
again right that being able to just go
out there and
see what happens with it because if it's
not a big deal to you
then it's not going to be a big deal to
other people if you make it a big deal
in your own head that's going to
subconsciously start to translate and
permeate out and it's going to make it a
big big deal for other people
in other areas too like if you're 5 6
and a dj you don't have to worry i had a
buddy i'm like dude how do you sleep
with chicks he was a gym buddy so like
more of a spotter type thing we never
hung out like dude like how do you do
this random club to a club one night
like pulled a girl right out from
underneath me like dude you're
disgusting what the hell guys
i'm like okay i can't compete with that
it's not a joke that's in the market
so here's how they think those so it's
yes yes women want the best that they
can do
but it's subjective
it's subjective through what they feel
like they feel like that is
it's not the subjective measure this is
where a lot of guys get on the internet
and they fuel guys insecurities oh well
objectively six foot tall is better more
you know so you can't get girls you want
if you're under that it's not how women
think or how their attraction triggers
work when guys approach things like that
i automatically know they suck with
women because they have no idea no idea
how well sure but then they have no idea
how women operate they haven't really
been around women or dated enough women
to see what happens and i got a good
start a quick anecdote to illustrate
this so a friend of mine is uh actually
he's in the acting thing he's gonna be
in a pretty huge movie with coming out
in the next year to like uh one of the
superhero movies and he's the lead and i
can't say anything more than that
because he's
it's it's all like non-disclosure
agreements and stuff right so this dude
is like jacked good looking dude but
guess what he's not super tall he's like
five seven
you know and so in hollywood he'll wear
shoe lifts so he's like five eleven
all right but he's really only about
five seven so he went out on it with a
date on a girl with a girl he had a nice
time whatever seemed good she never
called him back ghosted him
she went to a party found out he was
going to be the lead in this movie in an
act of course
and then she texted him back right it
was i was like whatever
do that to you they see your insurance
like oh whoa you have a jet ski like so
so
yeah yeah and so he he you know kind of
talked with her a little bit and kind of
got down to the root of what was the
reason for you not calling me back like
really and got her comfortable enough to
be able to tell him and she said well
you were a little bit shorter than me
and i was didn't really like that but
you know i i thought i'd give it a
chance i heard this his status
outweighed his height at that point now
he never went out with her again because
he wants genuine desire for
uh as far as being an alpha genetic
sexual option not for status money or
the other things he uses
so that's why a lot of guys there's a
debate whether to use that channel or
not i consider marketing channels yeah
all right well you know
okay finish up paul
yeah yeah yeah so the point is though
it's under a series of categories if
you're 5'6 but your confidence is up
your personality hits triggers for her
your game is good other things are good
about you she'll see you as a genetic
option to want to be with it doesn't
have to be status necessarily she will
change her mind her attraction in the
moment has a lot to do with her
subjective feelings that can change at
other moments and so you can't get hung
up on one insecurity or a trait you just
have to
elevate yourself in every other category
and you'll do just fine
you